[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir la actualidad
de la copa américa y la eurocopa a
continuación los titulares
'garra charrúa' guiados por un gol de
edinson cavani la selección de uruguay
venció a su similar de bolivia en la
cuarta fecha del grupo a
el conjunto que dirige oscar washington
tabárez ya empieza a pensar en su
posible rival en los cuartos de final de
la presente edición de la copa américa
tendremos análisis
dominio guaraní paraguay logró un nuevo
triunfo en el torneo al doblegar a la
selección de chile miguel almirón fue la
bujía del equipo que dirige eduardo
berizzo que espera llegar lejos en la
copa en chile- preocupa el cansancio por
el calendario de la competición tenemos
reacciones
comienza la eliminación directa con los
partidos cables dinamarca y austria
italia comienzan los octavos de final de
la euro 2020 los austriacos que se
clasificaron segundos en el grupo se
pondrán a prueba a la azzurri que quiere
estar entre los favoritos para la final
y como es su costumbre ya en nuestras
emisiones anteriores nos acompaña
sara castro directora del diario 'as'
colombia bienvenidas a un gusto luis
segundo día descanso de la eurocopa pero
mucho por conversar por supuesto que si
entramos en materia porque ayer la
selección de uruguay logró imponerse a
su similar de bolivia con marcador de 2
goles por 0 el resultado se traduce en
el primer triunfo de la celeste de este
el 13 de noviembre cuando en aquel
entonces derrotaron a la selección
colombia en el marco de las
eliminatorias los goles el día de ayer
fueron obras de jairo quinteros que
marcó en propia meta y edinson cavani
jugador que se reencontró con las redes
para su selección con este resultado así
queda el grupo argentina sigue liderando
la tabla con 7 puntos seguido de
paraguay que ayer venció a chile dos
goles por 0
uruguay se ubica en la cuarta casilla
con cuatro unidades
sara ayer vimos a una selección de
uruguay que atacó y dominó ampliamente a
una selección de bolivia pero será esto
suficiente para el conjunto que dirige
oscar washington tabárez para alcanzar
por lo menos instancias decisivas de
este torneo fue un muy buen partido de
uruguay aunque no estábamos descubriendo
nada así decimos que es el rival más
débil de la zona que es lo importante de
ayer que demostró que tiene jugadores de
calidad que aprovechó muy bien las
bandas y sobre todo que generó volumen
de juego ofensivo quien le había costado
mucho en los partidos anteriores de la
habíamos visto evolución ante chile pero
creo que esto sí pone de presente que
este uruguay tiene jugadores
inteligentes que tienen jugadores
desequilibrantes y seguramente y esto
volvemos a los lugares comunes del
fútbol y es con un equipo de la
jerarquía de uruguay seguramente lo pone
lo empieza a poner candidato en lo que
viene en la copa ayer anotó edison
cavani escuchemos la reacción del
jugador tras este partido
siempre es importante que un delantero
marque te da confianza y cabeza fría en
muchos momentos del partido pero aquí
como siempre hemos dicho lo más
importante es darlo todo por el equipo
no importa quién marque lo más
importante es ganar y seguir adelante
también habló el capitán de la selección
de bolivia juan carlos arze escuchemos
lo que dijo
estoy contento porque creo que tenemos
una nueva generación de jugadores que ha
ido mejorando y trabajaremos para
mantener nuestro crecimiento y estar al
más alto nivel para nosotros las
eliminatorias mundialistas serán
fundamentales una generación joven y
pensando en las eliminatorias
sara será esto suficiente para césar
farías obtendrá el venezolano el tiempo
suficiente para levantar un equipo que
ayer no lució bien el problema es la
competitividad en sudamericano y a ver
yo creo que es clave que bolivia
aproveche su localía en la paz y
seguramente esa va a ser un arma además
de todo este trabajo que está haciendo
farías con esta generación joven las las
eliminatorias en sudamérica son muy
complicadas e incluso a equipos que
están en un escalón un poco más arriba
como chile-colombia les ha costado
entonces es complicado de todas formas
como proceso siempre será interesante
ver el desarrollo de este tipo de
equipos en otro duelo de la jornada la
selección de paraguay venció dos goles
por cero a su similar de chile los goles
del partido fueron obra de brian
a los 33 minutos y miguel almirón a los
58 esta vez de pena máxima tras el
partido
los chilenos alegaron cansancio debido a
lo ajustado del calendario
ayer vimos un gran despliegue de
paraguay quizás uno de los mejores
partidos que han hecho en este torneo
pero es de preocupar está afirmación de
chile sobre lo ajustado del calendario y
el cansancio que arrastran los jugadores
vamos con lo primero creo que ya veréis
hoy ha demostrado que hacen muy buenos
planteamientos y ayer le ganó el duelo
táctico martín lasarte hizo un partido
muy interesante paraguay jugó con cinco
defensas le tapó los espacios corto los
circuitos de aránguiz y vidal fue un
partido muy muy bueno en el primer
tiempo un poco carente de ritmo en
general no fue muy vistoso el partido
pero demostró paraguay que tiene buenos
jugadores almirón otra vez poniendo una
pelota muy clara para el gol y creo que
eso es fundamental no también darle
crédito estos equipos que con una línea
menor de talento están compitiendo muy
bien ahora lo de chile es muy
interesante y muy importante tener en
cuenta porque tuvo un calendario similar
al de colombia y es que venían de dos
partidos
y empezaron la copa sin tener días de
descanso esto qué significa no solo
menos trabajo para adaptar la idea
táctica del entrenador sino también
menos oportunidad de que los jugadores
se recuperen y estamos viendo que ayer
faltó un jugador fundamental como es
eric pulgar que es un jugador que quita
y piensa mucho en chile y esas ausencias
por supuesto le costaron en el resultado
de ayer
hablaste que berisso le ganó el duelo a
lasarte en lo táctico pero escuchemos
qué fue lo que dijo el técnico chileno
sobre este partido
para ser honesto pensamos que paraguay
jugaría de otra manera considerando lo
que hemos visto
pensamos que jugaría 343 lo cual no
sucedió pero yo no quiero que este es el
problema podemos adaptarnos rápidamente
a este tipo de cambios podríamos decir
que berisso le movió el tablero a
lasarte para este partido si ya lo venía
haciendo a mí el partido contra
argentino me pareció súper interesante a
pesar del triunfo de argentina y esto es
lo que se tiene que ver en en estos
torneos y es la evolución de la idea de
estos equipos que reiteramos están
pensando además es en qatar pasamos a la
eurocopa mañana comienzan los octavos de
final del torneo y en donde italia
deberá enfrentarse a la selección de
austria en wembley inglaterra en otro
duelo la selección de gales se estará
midiendo a dinamarca que avanzó a estas
fases gracias a un triunfo en la última
jornada escuchemos lo que dijo marko
arnautovic el delantero de la selección
de austria sobre este partido
boti boti llevamos un equipo joven que
tiene hambre y queremos pasar esta ronda
no vinimos a este juego para decir hemos
alcanzado nuestro objetivo y ahora solo
jugamos y vamos de vacaciones más datos
en a ok we will creo que cada uno de
nosotros todavía quiere permanecer en el
torneo y ampliar la historia solidez
llegó la fase de eliminación directa
pero hablando de este partido
austria italia que presión podrían
ponerle los austríacos al combinado que
dirige roberto mancini me parecen muy
interesantes las declaraciones de
arnautovic porque hablan de el hambre de
una nueva generación de jugadores si no
se remonta la última victoria que tuvo
austria sobre italia es de 1960 en un
amistoso en nápoles esto habla de la
evolución de los procesos de ambos
equipos absolutamente diferentes
cuáles son las dos características o de
las dos figuras del equipo arnautovic en
la delantera y al agua que es un jugador
súper interesante que desde la defensa
ayuda muchísimo al equipo
de italia pues ya hemos hablado sin
descanso que es la mejor selección el
mejor colectivo porque tiene varios
registros porque hace las cosas muy bien
y creo que me quedo con una frase de
ratti que es fundamental y es dijo ayer
cada uno de nosotros sabe qué hacer y
eso se dice rápido pero es muy difícil
que un equipo
adquiera esa ese adn propio esa idea del
entrenador y la transmita en la cancha
el otro vuelo de las jornadas de este
sábado y el que abrirá realmente los
octavos de final está entre cal es que
parte como favorito ante la selección de
dinamarca escuchemos lo que dijo andreas
cornelius jugador tenía marca sobre este
plástico
pero debemos estar al tanto de 20 tiene
mucha calidad necesitamos estar
concentrados en él y no regalar tiros
libres y contraatacar lo active way
y que tenemos que tener cuidado con él
pero no demasiado
esta noche quiero decir que los otros
jugadores también pueden jugar
así que no es como si fuera un ejército
de un solo hombre
one man a menos un experimentado jugador
como gareth bale es el gran referente de
este combinado galés pero cuán
importante es el exjugador del real
madrid para este conjunto de cara a lo
que resta del torneo los focos están en
vail porque es un jugador de
características muy diferentes a las del
resto es un jugador que está por encima
del nivel y que a pesar de las
dificultades que ha tenido incluso
últimamente sabemos que en este tipo de
torneos ya lo ha demostrado y marca esa
diferencia me parecen muy interesantes
las declaraciones de hoy porque por qué
es eso
dinamarca que tiene es un equipo que es
el que más veces ha rematado al arco es
un equipo súper ofensivo y ese premio lo
tuvo en esta clasificación a los octavos
yo creo que vamos a ver muchas
transiciones de gales aprovechando esa
dupla bale ramsay y eso va a ser
interesante que en el momento en el que
dinamarca ataque y deje espacios
intenten ellos aprovecharlos con
velocidad creo que es un duelo como de
fuerzas muy muy equilibradas muy
balanceados creo que va a ser un partido
interesante a continuación la selección
de las principales
en ambos torneos
la uefa abrió una investigación
disciplinaria respecto a posibles
incidentes discriminatorios ocurridos
durante el partido entre alemania y
hungría llevado a cabo el 23 de julio
esta se sumarían las investigaciones que
llevan a cabo por presuntas acciones
racistas durante los partidos que se
efectuaron en budapest
lionel messi jugador de la selección de
argentina celebró el 24 de junio su
cumpleaños número 34 en medio de la copa
américa el jugador que desea el título
del torneo para su país permanece sin
contrato con su club el fc barcelona- y
de acuerdo con el diario 'as'
según la prensa peruana el delantero de
la selección de ese país ya educa la
patrulla presentaría un esguince en su
tobillo derecho producto de un golpe
sufrido en el partido frente a ecuador
el jugador uno de los cuatro no nacidos
en américa que disputa este torneo es
duda para el duelo frente a venezuela
de esta manera llegamos al final del
diario de copas continúen con más de la
programación de france 24 y france 24
puntocom
i